une visite avec une portée politique
certaine pour emmanuel macron on se
rendant sur le chantier de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris
il souhaite mettre en avant un symbole
de la résilience de la france et la
vitalité de ces entreprises alors que le
pays est frappé par la crise sanitaire
du coc vie de 19,1 parallèle
complètement assumé par le président de
la république dans un entretien accordé
au parisien ce jeudi
il décrit le chantier de la cathédrale
comme une métaphore des difficultés que
le pays est en train de traverser sur
les échafaudages de notre dame
emmanuel macron s'est adressé aux
ouvriers une prise de parole au sujet du
chantier mais qui aurait très bien pu
s'appliquer aux efforts fournis pour
lutter contre l'épidémie
un message voilà deux que fierté
collective parce qu'on a beaucoup fait
en deux ans et on a évité le pire a
remis un immense remerciements à toutes
celles et ceux qui sont mobilisés par
milliers d'années déjà sur ce chantier
35 entreprises forêts de france qui est
déjà mobilisé nos apprentis des
compagnons qui sont là en permanence
et puis on regarde aussi les trois ans
qui viennent
parce que c'est
c'est avec beaucoup de rigueur
professionnalisme et falloir tenir nos
objectifs et donc
cette grande mobilisation de
planification très exigeante et
rigoureuse et donc c'est aussi du
volontarisme on essaie la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par emmanuel macron est
largement critiqué au moment où la
france franchit la barre des cent mille
décès liés aux qu'ovide 19 et si
l'aspect symbolique de cette visite
n'est pas contestée par l'opposition
certains députés aimeraient voir
davantage d'implication de la part du
président de la république souhaiterait
qu'ils soient davantage présent
davantage efficaces en matière de
protection sanitaire de notre pays nous
avons tout le débat récurrent sur les
masques sur les vaccins qui n'arrive pas
suffisamment en doses importantes dans
nos vaccinodromes on a ouvert des
centres alors qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de doses aujourd'hui bien
sûr elles vont venir mais voilà je pense
qu'il serait non pas préférant mais qui
serait souhaitable que le président soit
au plus près de ses citoyens au plus
près de la crise sanitaire au plus près
de la crise économique et sociale plutôt
que de faire des visites on va dire
symbolique et d'envisager des réformes
qui sont mortifères comme la réforme sur
les retraites réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui vont être mortifère pour les
françaises et les français avec le
chantier de notre dame
emmanuel macron veut prouver qu'il peut
tenir ses promesses ils l'assurent les
délais de reconstruction seront tenus
quant au général jean louis georgelin le
président de l'établissement public
chargé de reconstruire la cathédrale
il reste plus mesuré il espère que des
offices puisse être célébrée en avril
2000 24 mais estime que les travaux de
reconstruction ne seront pas terminés
avant plusieurs années